début juillet le gouvernement a rejeté
la demande de fusion des départements
des hauts-de-seine et des yvelines
un projet porté par les présidents de
ces deux collectivités patrick devedjian
et pierre bédier pour évoquer ce sujet
nicolas landry et sur le plateau bonsoir
bonsoir régler le dossier se retrouve
t'il vraiment au point mort avec cette
décision gouvernementale alors grégory
dans les faits non le gouvernement a
effectivement refusé de créer par décret
un nouveau département issus de l'union
entre le 92 et le 78 un acte
administratif est essentielle pour
permettre l'aboutissement de ce projet
mais pierre bédier et patrick devedjian
peuvent néanmoins poursuivre les actions
déjà engagées
alors c'est un long processus en cette
fusion yvin hauts-de-seine pouvez vous
revenir sur les prémices de ce projet or
rappelez vous de ces images nous sommes
en janvier 2016 lors des voeux de la
nouvelle année une cérémonie commune
présidé par patrick devedjian et père et
pierre bédier pour annoncer la création
au mois de mars d'un établissement
public de coopération
interdépartementale une structure
dirigée par un conseil d'administration
composé par l'ensemble des quatre vingt
huit conseillers départementaux
la première pierre du projet de fusion
entre les hauts-de-seine et les yvelines
et quels ont été les premières décisions
prises sur 7 pour cette structure
premier choix la mutualisation des
services comme l'entretien et
l'exploitation du réseau routier
départemental
le service adoption et l'archéologie
préventive
autre mesure la création d'un aménageur
public commun appelé site alios pour
conclure des marchés publics ensemble ou
encore l'installation d'un conseil
interdépartementale du développement
durable le conseil d'administration a
aussi voté deux budgets
cinq cent mille euros en 2016 et 14
millions en 2010 cet objectif de toutes
ces mesures vous comprenez peut-être
réaliser des économies et permettre de
mener des politiques en commun alors ce
projet rencontre des oppositions et pas
seulement en provenance du gouvernement
effectivement en premier
on retrouve les députés de la république
en marge des yvelines je vous propose
d'écouter bruno myle yens le député de
la 9e circonscription mes petits
camarades de la république en marche
sont livrés une étude pour voir si ça
avait un sens ou pas quelles étaient les
quel était le département des deux
départements celui quart d'heure on ne
tirait les plus gros bénéfices
visiblement ce n'est pas forcément les
yvelines et notamment les territoires où
j'ai le document il à la disposition des
deux présidents s'ils veulent le
recevoir
ça serait plutôt des avantages des
territoires ruraux des yvelines alors il
y a une autre source d'opposition au
sein même de la majorité départementale
yvelinoise avec les conseillers
départementaux comme yves vandewalle qui
vous le voyez ça lui sur sa page twitter
la décision du gouvernement comme son
collègue philippe brillault en fait tous
les deux sont opposés depuis le début du
projet à cette fusion
mais ça n'enlève en rien la persévérance
du président du département des
hauts-de-seine qui se dit prêt à avoir à
recourir par des moyens judiciaires à
quelques jours seulement après l annonce
du gouvernement
merci nicolas et pour conclure sur ce
dossier pierre bédier devrait évoquer le
sujet mercredi lors d'un déjeuner presse